hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast challenges and
opportunities building IT capabilities
to support large-scale on its projects
in a health system I'm Julie am tired of
labyrinth and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them into the Q&A
box which can be found by clicking on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the side window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button on the lower left this webinar
has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
cee button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits I would now like to introduce
today's speaker and black n black is
more than 15 years of IT and business
experience consolidating and managing
large and complex data sets from
disparate sources he holds many
certifications in both technical and
project managers at inova Translational
Medicine Institute lapidus team are
building a world-class bioinformatics
infrastructure for the Institute's
massive and very data to support
genomics research and clinical services
and ultimately for the purpose of
translating genomics research and
medical discoveries for improved patient
care previously mr. black was the
informatics manager and leader for the
biospecimen pool resource at Nationwide
Children's Hospital and the National
Cancer Institute Genome Atlas Project he
was co architect for the flexibility
a model to store and access data from
studies for more than 30 cancer subtypes
and clinical data from bio banks and
academic institutions across five
confident I will now turn it over to
Aaron black for his presentation thank
you very much it's a pleasure to be here
today to give his presentation and
before i do i do want to plug another
presentation today about 30 minutes
after i'm done dr. ven Solomon will be
doing more the scientific part of this
presentation where I'm gonna be dealing
with more informatics and IT Ben is
Delta going to drill down into the
science and the application of that
within our healthcare system so if you
if you are more interested or it's just
as interested map these zones in the
been here about about half hour dr. weir
complete so I want to start with my
presentation now which is really looking
at the challenges and opportunities we
have to build these IT capabilities to
support the research the clinical
application of genomics so today just to
start as I get used to the interface is
to do an outline just to give you an
idea of what we're going to talk about
today so first I want to give context to
what we do here at inova and in
particular at the ANOVA Translational
Medicine Institute you know why we do it
who we are and i'll give you a context
of our health system which is where
we're doing this work secondly we will
look at the challenges so the more data
we have the bigger challenges that we
have in front of us particularly when
we're trying to support the research and
the scientists and the clinical
applications last sliver next we need
opportunities so just because there's a
lot of challenges doesn't mean there's
other opportunities that we see in the
market how do we leverage those how do
we make ourselves better now that we've
been doing this for a while and then
really wrap up with a couple things
which is you know what's next what are
we seen in the market what are we seem
to enable you know our research our
clinical some some next-generation types
of IT applications and then I wrap it up
a little bit of less
learned so as we've been doing this here
at inova nit mi which is again the anova
Translational Medicine Institute what do
we learn what are we trying to do and
make ourselves better so hopefully
you'll get a good snapshot of what's
happening really on the ground here at
inova so moving on to our first slide
we're going to talk about you know who
we are what we do at innova and I'll try
to move through these pretty quickly but
it give you some context of really what
we are what we do know gut is located on
the east coast so mid-atlantic region of
the United States just to give you an
example of kind of geography here where
r inova fairfax hospital which is our
anchor hospital one of six is about 15
miles outside of Washington DC so we're
in a very geographically diverse region
lots of population and our hospital
system is a comprehensive network and
you can see that here in the slides and
I wanted to give it just a little bit
about the numbers these are a couple
years old but just about the size of the
scope of what we do here at inova and
the new bug about this is back in two
thousand probably 10 2011 knew that
personalized precision medicine was
going to be it was going to be the next
step now they probably didn't call it
that way but they wanted to translate
this data into you know proof patient
care which you can see here on the on
the left side of the slide but when we
started it was founded by dr. John meter
Huber who at the time had just come in
from the National as director of the
National Cancer Institute and so it
started one person and about we're now
about six little over five years old
going into our sixth year and now we've
grown and so you can see on the right we
have about 90 full-time employees that
are part of our Institute and that split
is really about a third lab a third
clinical and a third eye teen of
romantics which is the group that I work
with on the technical side lab technical
side we have a research lab and we have
a CLIA certified clinical lab the
clinical side that's really a
combination of people who
senting patients that are drawing blood
and getting that to the laboratory and
there's all wide ranges of clinical
services that we provide from even data
entry and data quality on the IT side we
kind of split that amongst
infrastructure really data management
the data modeling as well as
bioinformatics so that gives you kind of
an idea of the team that we built here
at itm I and then really move it on to
you know what kind of studies do we do
we have so again we have a research
component or translational research
component we now support / 12 studies
within the health system highlight a
couple ease here and you know even some
of these numbers are maybe three or four
months old so we have probably close to
4,000 families that we've enrolled so
our major studies are related to infant
birth so a preterm study a longitudinal
study and then a disease on rare rare
variants within our neonatal intensive
care unit and when we do our studies we
are doing these in what we call trios
which is mother father and intent so we
have the family unit for most of these
larger studies which are here on the
left-hand side we have an integrated bio
bank so we track the specimens we not
only do whole genomes for our patients
or for our studies but we'd also do
other RNA sequencing methylation
expressions we tried to do a lot of the
systems biology approach but what you're
seeing here is there's just a lot of
data that we're tracking on the IT side
that has to be you know put into a
actual place that our scientists can
work with so again for context there's a
lot of data that we're tracking in about
two years ago we also started a genomics
the innovation with laboratory or igl
and this is a clinical testing facility
clia-certified so really what we've been
doing for the first couple years was a
lot of research project and we continue
to do that but we've now evolved into
doing actual testing for our clinical
system so just a couple examples of
things we do today one being
pharmacogenomics so we have a couple of
variations of that and we're going to
drill
the informatics part of this but we do
pharmacogenomics where we can do
individual drugs based on point of care
and what we'd rolled out more recently
early this year is a panel from chemical
genomic panels that's a lot a lot of a
lot of words there but we turn that into
this brain in meddy map so we do seven
genes and we are right now rolling that
out to all of our infants they have to
consent to it the parents do but they're
able to get their babies happen to have
a comprehensive panel seven genes and
and really tried true alleles and what
they do to those babies and we store
those within the health record we also
do cancer panels and right now we use
those for our molecular tumor board but
we also use those for the patients who
you know we can treat their tumors more
precisely by doing those panels
informatica lee obviously that presents
a lot of challenges because this is new
for typical EMR systems so epic in
particular is our EMR or electronic
medical record and electronic health
record so right now when we do
pharmacogenomics we do custom reports we
spent a lot of time to modify those so
that our clinicians are comfortable with
theirs what they're seen because
sometimes this is the first time they've
seen a report like this and then we also
parse these into discrete results and
we'll go into what hl7 is but that's the
mechanism of how we exchange this
information and their standards that we
have to adhere to but when we want to
put these into our EMR we have knowledge
base vendors who support us when we're
you know how to keep those knowledge
bases up to date and then we're starting
to develop with epic terms best practice
alerts which are really clinical
decision support so as a patient comes
in and they want to get a drug
prescribed we're able to alert them to
you know is this treatment is this drug
going to be good or bad for them and so
we're trying to integrate all this data
into the healthcare system and then the
cancer panels same thing not as mature
as pharmacogenomics when it comes to the
knowledge base and also to the parsing
of that but we're very much integrated
into the development of that with with
the standards of hl7 so what does that
do that's the context well the learning
healthcare system is kind of play
term but the data we have to bring
together so we can treat our patients
better and that's what the slide is
really about it's hard when you do with
this type of data both the bigger data
and I would call the non-standard and
messy data you know we need to bring
this to a whole and there's a kind of
the way that we build our teams is a
cross-functional team to support you
know the vision of the healthcare system
and then really the last couple slides
here about ANOVA are really what's
coming in the future so again to give
you context anova has put a significant
investment in developing precision
medicine personalized medicine
translational medicine our Institute and
then they're going to be rolling this
out to a bigger campus ICP H stands for
the anova Center for personalized health
so really moving into a what health and
wellness type of areas opposed to
treating necessarily always treating
people who have already been sick so
just to give you a little bit about the
campus innova bought the X exxonmobil
world headquarters which is literally
right across the street it's a it's an
already established building about 1.3
million square feet so a very large
footprint but it's on a bigger campus
and will show this in the next slide
this slides related showed you know this
is really a connected part so over here
is Washington DC this is where the
campus is and if you look at the next
slide here the vision of the campus
right now is where I'm sitting over here
at the fairfax campus so it's a pretty
large health system campus but you can
see the size of the new campus and will
show you the buildings now they're
building this as a again a place to
attract world-class researchers
diplomatists specialty clinics
technology and life sciences services
and if you look at I just wanted to show
a couple of buildings and what they've
kind of triggered them for so this is
the entire campus excuse me so one of
the things we are building it's already
started construction is the innova
Dwight Martha char Cancer Institute we
had a generous donation by the sharra
the char family and that would be where
we have a like a full 360 cancer center
right on campus and then where my group
is going to go is this really what
they're turning a Technology Center and
so my team along with the hell
care systems along with a lot of new
technology places or services will be
located in this building so again
looking for context you have a health
system who's now put their money in a
translational research center like ours
is starting to do clinical testing in
small increments of chromosome almost in
an increment in an agile way and it's
been really starting to build upon that
with the new center so with that context
that presents a lot of challenges that
is not what they're what they're looking
to do is not trivial especially in a
position where I'm at which is to help
build and support these these broad
visions so really the start I wanted to
really tackle this kind of dichotomy
between health care and research so my
previous experience has been in more on
the business medical billing side until
about nine years ago when I got into a
project called the Cancer Genome Atlas
it was really my first foray into
building a research system and so these
first couple slides are really to kind
of highlight that when you're trying to
build or research focused organization
within a larger health care system there
can be challenges in a lot of ways we
consider so it's kind of a startup
within a healthcare system so you know
they're complementary missions and we
want to embrace those but there are also
some things that are different so our
example a healthcare will focus more on
patient care in patient safety whereas
in a research where you know we want to
build studies we want to do the analysis
we want to do you know our work and that
can be kind of different when we're
looking at how the IT systems are
focused we're on the healthcare side
we're looking at security redundancy up
time billing where and research we want
to be fast and when an agile we want to
you know we want to support the
scientists in the way that their minds
work which sometimes can be you know
just that's moving and a lot of this
technology can be trained in and I put
that there because sometimes you know
this could be here for a year or two but
then the year or two it might not be so
sometimes there's not that long-term
focus of building an integrated system
or a set of services that can be
leveraged by multiple researchers or
projects and that's where you know
sometimes we struggle now the other
thing is the way that healthcare is
zar you know they're protected and
that's for good reason we want to
protect our patient data but when you
one of the money on the research side
especially in these large-scale genomics
projects we want to share we want to
collaborate we obviously don't have all
the knowledge in the rule about this so
what we do is just in this kind of a
little bit more of a character trigger
what's going on you know we intend to
firewall or data technology when it
comes to the clinical systems and we
only get preferred people access to
those and do a lot of stringent
collaborations with them to make sure
everything is secure on the research
side we still have to have that security
but the due diligence sometimes you know
you see this dichotomy here are going to
be using clinical security parameters
for research data and that's where we
have to come to that harmony of what
those secure the secure measures are
because you know we're sharing with
multiple partners we want to publish
papers we want to download information
and it's my job and my team's job the
broker all that to make sure we're doing
the best we can and making sure that we
have the tightest security policies
needed so what does that do so that's
really a high level but when you get
into the actual data information there's
even a little bit of changes that I've
seen so when I first came in a lot of
the places that I had been they saw
their data that looks something like
this a huge you know repository of data
that was codified like a library you
could look things up you know you had to
grab the information in the book but you
wanted it all coated and but really this
is not reality that's not what happens
Lina and I joke here when I show this
the screen but it sometimes looks a
little bit more like this which is where
we just pile things on top of each other
and I'll kind of people go on to their
your SharePoint or your shared directory
and you see these just just files and
files and files we need to find some
happy to lend here you can't we're not
on either side of that spectrum we don't
want to be we want to be somewhere in
the middle which is knowing where the
information is encoded fine correctly
which is where again you know health
care systems a little bit different when
they when they talk about data standards
a lot of their data standards are built
for billing and government regulations
you know high-tech rules and meaningful
use and then billing you know they need
their
they need to get they need to get paid
and so a lot of the times when they do
that that can be misleading for our
researchers who aren't sure if that's
really the diagnosis that should be
associated with what happened to that
that infant or a child at that time and
in general we find that you know the hrs
it's a federal mandate for us to be on
the HR within a health system but it's
still fairly new and in many cases you
see just some some maturity that's
needed in certain areas even within a
health system itself so you know health
care is now started to embrace that
standardization but it's still early on
the research side you know the concepts
great but it's really hard to implement
especially when you're dealing with
multiple research organizations and of
course there's always something new
that's coming at us and your data type
and you a new just something new so on
both sides where we're at in our health
systems we're trying to straddle over
those now here's a little bit of more of
a visual and let me see if I can do some
of these tools with this slide so when I
first got here I got to ennoble about
the two and half years ago and of course
the actual work no I TMI is about five
years old so they had a couple years of
head start of generating data so one of
the first things we tried to do when we
got here was just let's quantify what's
going on like where's the data how is it
coated what do we need to do one of the
gaps and what we found was and we've
been along we've been doing a whole
genome sequencing for about five years
is they had two different types of
vendors with us so they have started
often you can see here in the corner I
make it my mouse here that they have
started with complete genomics so one of
our studies one of our larger studies
was done on Complete Genomics platform
but Complete Genomics was bought by
Beijing vgi and of course they stop
servicing us so we needed to move to
another vendor so we started to work
with aluminum so Illumina platform and
what you see on the screen is really two
different types of data so across the
top here you have just the file size and
gigabytes so from zero to six hundred
you can see there's quite a bit of
variation here for the orange which is
the Complete Genomics but then you see
here in luminal and it's very consistent
and actually if you look at this one
particular piece and I know there's a
nice little tool for this one and do a
box so you can kind of see this area
right here is almost bimodal what
happened was alumina this is where the
data gets messy sometimes that they'd
have been deposited twice so these are
individual people these are just RT
identified identifiers and so they
deposited twice so you see aluminum
pretty good pretty consistent and then
we got a second everyone so we're
finding ways this is actually a big
report that we do in tableau which is a
nice tool for visualization and we just
noticed this in sin why are they like
this we can highlight these we look at
them and say well they're actually in
our in our repository twice so when the
shows you just really quickly is the
variation of data we get I mean look at
all of the nests you know how do we know
any have them all how do we know all the
data correctly and that was one of the
first challenges that we have when we're
looking at these large-scale genomics
data so to move on to the next slide
this is kind of a big level when we
drill down a little bit further let's go
down to the next slide then we started
to ingest those those files and so for
those of you who know this these are
variant level kind of tables here and
one of the things we found was you know
if you store these things as flat files
that's fantastic a lot of people are
used to command line and they can they
can access this data but we needed a
central place to put that to make sure
that we had all the data that it was
connected to our patient records or
phenotypic information and so we did is
we in the past year and a half we build
a Duke cluster I am use a tool called
Impala and in what Paula does is it
makes these flat files look like they're
in a relational systems you can write
sequel queries to do that in stunning
and it uses MapReduce and a lot of
in-memory infrastructure to run these
things very quickly so it's nice and it
can scale but what you'll see here is
when we run this query we actually have
two different files now because the
Complete Genomics variant files are
quite a bit different than the aluminum
files and we've done a bunch of
normalizations and we've
a very great group out of Seattle
Institute persons of biology to really
try to blend these as best as possible
but we actually have to your files named
the same thing but they're a different
schema so when I run when we run this
code but you're going to see and I'll do
my little thing here is that these are
my sample IDs on the side so many grand
mite piece here so what you have is you
know the sample IDs and then you have
the number of variants that are coming
out of the file with the custom
filtering do that try to normalize the
state is best possible and we've
iterated over this multiple times and
you can see that these numbers are quite
a bit different these are actually
different people these aren't exact
match to match because again we're doing
a lot of comparisons but on the very
inside you can see that they're kind of
different and when we do the summary
here the averages and just to give you a
number here alumina is probably around
five thousand different samples that we
tracked and on the Complete Genomics
side is about three thousand but you can
see when we look at the averages of how
many are in variants are in each file
there's about forty percent difference
now most of that's on references and
quality scores but that creates a you
know a difference and again when we're
looking to prepare this for scientific
use it can be challenging and the other
thing is this is getting quite large and
for those of you who are working with
large scale genomics you know that this
can get quite large and the CPU and
storage costs can be quite large so just
to give you an idea what we're looking
at or just looking at just bearing its
we're not looking at clinical data
annotations any of the pipeline stuff
that's coming off of this you know these
are the kind of around numbers of
genomes that we've now adjusted about a
three hundred number of rows totaled so
when you give the average and again
these are just raw numbers for you
that's about two hundred and eight
billion rows of alumina data about 63
billion and complete genomics when we
did our normalization this is how many
columns so we do kind of a matrix you
know our total data point tracked it's
somewhere in the seven trillion row area
and that's not something you put into a
excel spreadsheet or even into access or
a traditional relational system
big things but we have to address those
variations so that we can do our work
effectively in high quality and even
drilling down even further so this is
when the kind of transition to the
actual test themselves so you build
these large systems in order to
translate this to better patient care
and in our genomic testing we're
starting to do that too now I'm kind of
disappointed in that I didn't do this
better but there's a lot of standard
codes that are out there that we're
trying to adhere to so link is and I
wrote it down here it is a logic logical
observation identifier and it's a system
that is online that helps us with
laboratory codes so as you you know as
meaningful use and health care systems
need to standardize this is one of the
things they standardized to so every lab
should have a one code that describes it
and you can barely see this over here
but this is an actual just identifier
that says this is the light code for the
test that I'm providing or of the result
of that test and there's about a
thousand so if I got to linking it's
about 80,000 100,000 different codes
that you have the opportunity to try to
use if you go out there for molecular
genetics and you can barely see this but
it says molecular pathology and mutation
or by Mt if I look a particular gene you
see all kinds of things that come back
and it's very confusing for us when we
went out there for the first time say we
want to do a pharmacodynamic code how do
we codify and this is where we started
which was you know what are our
standards how do we now take that in
apply it to clinical care so to give you
an example of some of the things that
were we're actually still trying we're
helping define and we're still trying to
work with users and experts in both link
and hl7 which is the way that health
systems exchange information to
understand how do we do this in genetics
and genomics so a lot of these things
are still going to find and we're trying
to work with these groups to do this so
just to give you an example and I will I
put this in here it's a very much an
oversimplification but sometimes we have
to do this in order to understand the
challenges for people who don't deal
with us on a day-to-day basis like many
of you is if we're doing a kind of a
simple variant and we're
the rep in the alternate in our sequence
you know maybe that's codify to
something called blue but we do a
complex variant which is just one or
more or two on one you might have one
that says blue when this is yellow but
what do you want to codify that what do
you call it do you call it green because
that's the combination you put it on a
pallet and grew again this is civil
simplified but what if there's three and
four you call them what the combination
of those colors are what's the you know
the actual interpretation of those
together do you you know codify them in
one long string or you're just kind of
adding them together you know what is
the standard for that and that's what's
still really being worked on when it
comes to doing this and then structural
variations are very difficult to codify
so now you know in that same scenario
the other one blue were switched and
there was a sequence inserted in the
middle again very oversimplified but
then what do you call that you know that
that's where when you put this in a
discrete element not a report with an
interpretation what do you call those
those variations and these are things
that
and as it continues to escalate so again
I'm tweet what all the challenges are
eventually you get into simple variants
complex variants and in structural
variations then actually I didn't want
to go back one slide the you know when
you get into things that aren't just
simple pharmacogenomics and you want to
look at transcriptions and genomics and
alleles each one of those has
codifications that we have to track so
what ends up happening when you're in
that kind of research mode where you're
building a set you see the results now
we have to look at what's coming off the
machine was it called really trying to
do in what context are we trying to run
this panel what identifies are out there
that are standards for so for example in
cancer and limited cosmic and for each
one these tests then we have a lot of
work to do on the IT and informatics I
to make sure that these things are coded
appropriately which is you know again
where we're at right now with a lot of
our tests and working with some of the
standards committees hl7 going to to
evaluate these because it's one thing to
have a standard but then can you get is
it actually good in practice and that's
where we're at right now so again you
know as we develop these tests we're
going to have to be evaluating the most
test by test to see how to encode them
effectively and then no share them
because a lot of us is what is the
utility if you're going to do the
sequencing if you don't have the
discrete results on codified some way
how do you know the value of it when
something new is gained so what if
there's new knowledge how do we go back
and find out what happened it is
embedded in a PDF report there's many
times that you know we can't scan for
those you can't build clinical decision
support for now drug interactions for
clinical trials for particular therapies
we know little una will not work so
we're in an interesting point but in an
overworked we're really trying to push
forward with this so I want to
transition a little bit kind of got into
some details and visuals on kind of what
we're doing but really generally we have
a lot of challenges when it comes to
scaling you know genomics just basically
because of the size which is always the
first thing which is scale how do you
you move from a genome 25 gino's 200
genomes various panels various other
types of data you know RNA sequencing
micro micro RNA methylation microbiome
is is now something that we're
interested in an era reflecting some of
our protocols so how does that all come
together so it's always always been an
issue security obviously that overlays
everything especially when we're dealing
with clinical data I do want to
highlight staff staff is I mean this
technology is really quite rapidly it's
really a convergence of biotechnology
and IT that is coming to the forefront
so to find people that can work in the
space is very very difficult and then
lastly and i put here that now really
thirty percent of my job is to evaluate
new technology may be no we need help no
we need people that can support various
aspects of ordering the tests you doing
the analysis to storing to returning
those results so you know right now we
have a lot of people out a lot of really
great solutions but you know we really
have to make sure that it's not just
more of a sales pitch it's it's
technology that's going to work for our
or our business which is genomics and
really the one that I wanted to
highlight today in particular is because
there's been a lot of work with storing
data so what are you the storage
provider is very cheap and compute by
using cloud services even if you buy
on-premise architectures you really can
get a lot of value out of those but the
one thing that is probably the biggest
bottleneck for us when we try to scale
this is moving the data around so in my
little on play here we have really
massive amounts of data so if you have
more than a terabyte of data that you're
working with trying to move that to
another location I try to make this as a
parent it's a really small piece of
bandwidth it has to move that data and
it's very hard to update your bandwidth
if you're an existing building or an
existing place trying to open up walls
to put bigger cords and so typically
this is the biggest bottleneck for us
right now it is moving this day around
and so we're trying to find ways to not
move it so much and really that's where
the business comes in and I know that's
not the sexiest thing for us to look in
research but generally when it
healthcare system they want to look
you know you're spending a lot of money
to build these really big things but you
know what are we getting out of that
what is what is really happening and I
think that's really difficult to measure
when you're looking at research and even
on the clinical side when you're doing
these tests for the first time it's
going to take some time to establish
what the metrics are for success so you
know as these as the data generation
costs fall so as the sequencing it's
cheaper and machines are more and more
widespread the data or the costs are
moving from generation to storage and
that's really growing the data
management stuff that we do is actually
that cost is going quite quite
substantially and of course there's
always going to be this pressure to
publish to developing products to
recruit brand yourself and those are
things that we've seen in the market
right now and a lot of this is hidden
from from you know cause so these things
are very complicated and you know
whether you're improving the firewalls
or you're proving your network bandwidth
you have to train people up or maintain
these great things you build you got to
maintain them too there's a cost and
then of course a lot of the work that we
do is also trying to educate our
business and what we were doing these
are complicated things that we're all
working on how do we you know basically
articulate that to people who don't do
this on a day-to-day basis so those are
a lot of the challenges on this business
side and then I put this slide here
because I have a handful pet peeves that
I always put into some of my slides you
know one of the ones and these are
actually somewhat recent we have a
particular biological data vendor and
this is kind of widespread you know that
your sequencing machines where they put
servers and things next to them for the
for the interfaces and they don't really
think about security they don't think
about how we operated so we have one
machine that has a windows-based
operating system on it and for those of
you don't know when as these is super
old and when we went to go to upgrade
they said well we won't upgraded you're
going to have to buy a new machine and
we said okay what's that cost and it was
quite expensive so just know when you
get into this that some of these IT
vendors are not the best when it comes
to the data vendors are not so good at
supporting their machines and we've had
a lot of again this is my pet peeve a
lot of that going on a second one which
is a little bit different because I
a part of the Cancer Genome Atlas one of
the biggest things that we run into we
ran to there and then run into now is
when researchers typically think about
identifier they want to talk about them
and so for example in this example
they're codifying different things like
that might be the site this other things
let me go ahead and my screen here this
might be the site here this might be the
D identified patient number this is the
sample type this is how many vials there
are any way they're codifying this and
very early on they made this that
identifier and the problem is if you
ever miss put in one of these
identifiers you've just coded something
you're wrong and you can't change it so
um you know you can print the nice
identifiers on your laboratory material
to run reports but generally we like
unique identifiers that our database
driven I know some people get annoyed by
you know you you IDs or identifiers but
generally we want to keep those things
separate and the last one which is
personal to me is you know there's a lot
of work right now being done on be
called data models so you're getting all
this information from all over the place
how do you build a kind of a standard
location for that and what we find is
that there's a lot of over engineering
going on right now with you know how
states it so that really is a lot of the
challenges and so I spent a lot of time
on that probably a little too much on
that so I'm going to jump right into the
opportunities and you forward and a lot
of opportunities are actually
surrounding this kind of investment that
people are making in in healthcare and
trying to move this from you know how to
treat people that have already gotten
disease to moving towards more of a
proactive predictive model which is
treating people and then be incentivized
for treating them better and this is
more of a slide that the health system
promotes which is you know as we move
from in two thousand on forward be the
amount of cost that is sushi with health
care is growing exponentially but I
actually like this one a little bit
better I saw this this particular graph
at a National Academy of Sciences a
presentation and who loved it and what
this is is a representation of the US
and the United States against every
other kind of like country that is
economically similar so think sweden
france germany
european countries that have the same
resources and what you can see is that
the ages of people this is mortality
rate so what right you are and the
higher you are on this list of better
you are this is the u.s. charter and
from zero to ninety five you can see the
u.s. is not doing so well but then right
when you get to 65 they do really really
well so if you can make the 65 the
United States you know you do really
well but until then you're not all you
know you're not on par with what the the
international standard is and so again
we want to move that curve down so that
we're treating people better and that's
again a momentum thing for what's going
on the other thing is there's a huge
consumer demand for you know joe mix a
lot of the things that are being written
a lot of the companies that are being
invested in are these you know direct to
consumer and genomic engines so the
demand is there it's not that people
don't the one try this or want to be
part of this it's just doing it right
that's really a key but there's
opportunities there for health care
systems to do this right and then in
general because of that you know right
now in ANOVA in other places that we
talk to there's a lot of collaborations
going on there's a lot of shared
research and again the backbone of that
from an IT perspective is very
interesting to us you know whether those
are consortiums that are being built in
particular diseases or disease cohorts
public-private partnerships so
pharmaceutical companies partner in
health care systems and a lot of venture
capital and philanthropy is going on
right now that you know I think it's an
opportunity for us to really invest a
lot in this research and at the
application of that from a from a pure
information technology perspective you
know for us you know we started to use a
lot of cloud services because it's
really young small to start investing in
it again you need is a different
paradigm you haven't dealt with it you
do have to do some learning but it's
scalable a lot of API is
programmatically accessible it's a great
a great thing for us to scale and
they're building a lot of what we call
you go system partner so they're
latching on to those those AP is and
really building some really cool things
that are scalable and
affordable for us especially with
budgetary concerns and my recommendation
on cloud is make sure you build in your
controller to control the costs because
even though it's effective it can get
out of control you know make monitor and
maintain it we've used a lot of what
they called tagging so we're at Amazon
user on and we tag a lot of our
instances or your data so we can do
actually some kind of metric on what's
happening it was using what because a
lot of it is is not as hard to end
monitor and then you know we try to
lessen all the choices early I mean
Amazon's got like 50 services and at the
very end or list some of the ones that
we use but these things that can be
overwhelmed so we try to make sure our
scientists know exactly what they can
use it how to use it instead of just
giving them the keys to the castle other
opportunities on the data side I'll go
through this fairly quickly but there's
a lot of flavors of what we use so again
we use Hadoop we have an in-memory HPC
environment we use common our data store
in Amazon called red shift we have
partners that use graph databases and
other open source tools so we don't
believe that one database will rule them
all on it's definitely application
specific and in general when you're
looking at these consider the trade-offs
between what is good what is bad I mean
people will sell you just about anything
um so look at that kind of speed versus
cost parameters are you going to do this
batch or even to do this is a streaming
kind of capacity and then how do they
how do they do software upgrades and
Persians so again you have to maintain
this going forward so these are some of
the checklist items that we do as we're
evaluating software and I think that
comes them on one of my last ones which
is you know right now when I first got
into this eight years ago the maturity
of the vendors people who are trying to
sell you tools and technologies were
pretty pretty very very very new but as
they mature as they have both failures
and successes I think that there's more
and more valid options that are out
there which you know can be good and bad
depending on where you read on trying to
build something and then again just kind
of wrap that up you know what amount the
push to do this government academia
yeah you know the consortium's are
coming together and trying to build
these things and I think you have to
push even though it might not be perfect
I had to push forward to get that
information and then optimization so
once you've built that how you start to
know how good you're doing what are your
metrics I know that again that's not
necessarily what you think about first
but in order to keep this going I think
you have to look at doing this right so
to kind of wrap up here the last couple
slides you know what do we thinks next
and I'll between these fairly quickly
because I'm running a little bit low on
time but what we built here in ANOVA and
our research environments are different
networks so we really try to build what
we call hybrid cloud and there's
different terms for hybrid cloud but
ryan when we say that that means we're
blending cloud services with on prem and
of course you know we have to bridge a
little bit of the research and clinical
systems too and so we're trying to build
this but it's really not a template for
this we're trying to figure out the best
use cases for what we're doing and what
we've really try to do is automate that
so what's next for us is complete
automation of data ingestion data
quality of pipelining and then move it
in between these networks with
automation and tracking so this is just
a really quick animation as the colors
get darker that means we're processing
that data more and more so this might be
you know biological data coming in to
Amazon you through our different data
sources pipelines it's hard to get soon
it gets really really fast and then we
have is a nice HPC environment on a
research Network which is where you know
we want people to work and and then on
another routes we have our clinical
systems we do a lot of modeling d
identifications or separate even kind of
route it gets moved through but again we
want to have a central place where this
data is going so when a scientist comes
in they know where that data is they
don't have to kind of figure out which
is bubble it's in and do I have access
to you have a central controller on it
and each one of those colors we want to
make sure that you know that's the
fastest we're doing the most bang for
our buck so if it's in memory that's
expensive versus a long term and tape
storage or glacier which is an Amazon
and we're definitely costing to you
to think about and then again we are now
building hybrid appliances that can make
our research environment are a cloud
environment for research in our internal
research network look like they're the
same environment so not moving the data
so much so we said bottlenecks or
movements of data we're finding that
there's a nice ecosystems that are being
built where we don't have to move it we
can present it as if it's local but of
course there's bandwidth issues and it
can be expensive and I won't go through
too much of this video will be on out
here online where we've been doing a lot
of testing where and again this doesn't
show up so well but the green is when we
do all on-prem calculations so this was
testing some quality control and bam
files and you can see these are the
number of seconds so this is probably
four or five six hundred seconds to run
an actual QC on a BAM file and then we
started to say well what if we do the QC
using compute resources that are on our
on premise network to what's going on in
the cloud and you can see once we
prepare them these hybrid appliances is
actually much faster so it eliminates
the movement and there's costs
associated with this but generally we're
finding that the initial use cases of
quality control for us make this hybrid
cloud a viable option for us and then
automation so just the time out of this
last a minute or so you know we are
using a lot of amazon right now and
we're trying to build lambda which is a
service that runs code they called micro
services so instead of having to build
big computers you can run it at hawk and
get built or just what you run you know
simple workflows moving back and forth
you know logging and making sure that we
know what's going on cloud formation
staying up automated configuration
management data pipelines again a lot
more to this but generally we want to
automate as much as possible and then
finally my last slide is a couple slides
here which I'll run through very quickly
the lessons learned that we've had by
building these things over the last
three or four years bigger is not better
you want to put a bunch day in there
that quality is always going to win you
have to have size that quality is
definitely something you should you
should keep in mind
then your is going to try to trade offs
between speed and then what the costs
are especially when it comes to of these
elastic networks where you can do things
very quick but you're going to spend a
lot of money early on versus kind of
economy moving that across standard
technologies again make sure you're
trying to find these technologies that
work for you not just which are being
sold focus on execution sometimes
especially in our world there's so many
cool things you want to do them all try
to do them in an internet manner that's
something we learn we try to do too much
too early create cross-functional teams
you know try to try to do this
communication very very well I
understand what they need not just build
it and think that they're going to come
to it presentation this data again is
large but a lot of times the
presentation that data is even more
important than what you're doing we
found that specifically in clinical
testing that's very important of how you
represent this and then again there's
not one database that we found that we
could just jam it all into we've really
tried to to blend the right types of
data into the right types of systems but
always tracking those things that
informatica ly so we know what's there
and how big is so that's the end of my
presentation I appreciate your time I
think I'm going to pull it over QA now
and this is just my last credit slide
thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you could submit
questions by typing them into the Q&A
box which can be found by clicking on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can our
first question how do you add
environmental factors influence of
personalized health management into the
data question due to cancer cluster of
East Harris County Texas from industrial
staff
so so that's a very good question and
okay here we're just starting to get
into the environmental factors so we're
writing some grants with some
collaborators who actually do a lot with
about environmental factors so it's a
very interesting space what we've been
trying to do now is just when we enroll
our patients we do know where they live
so for an environmental factor if you're
looking at you know what's the air
quality of where they're living what are
they what are they doing we're working
with a group that we know where they
live you know when they move because we
be pulled in every six months our
studies are longitudinal so we can ask
those questions and then we're trying to
use these again other resources to help
us to interpret that what how do we use
that data how do we kind of blend those
to the other way we do environmental is
we do surveys so we have things like
again from an infant verse perspective
we ask them you know the nutritional
questions that are very standardized and
kids scored we ask them you know about
their living environment are they still
with the husband what is there you know
have they been laid off do they work
things that we can track across you know
so what are those factors and how do
they influence is their disease
management so we have a pretty small
subset I mean you don't do this across
the entire health system so our co-host
co-host 10 or 15,000 people but some
these are kind of ways that we're trying
to track not just the genomics but the
environmental factors mean your physical
environment which are cycles social
environment your nutrition and I think
that's going to mature quite a bit as we
expand our services to try to integrate
that data in but I think it's going to
be it's going to be challenged
the next question what is the IT cost
contribution to the overall genetic test
costs so the IT cops there's there's
many of them I would say it's a
somewhere around thirty to forty percent
of the overall cost only because you
have to when you're building these
systems a lot of them require
specialized software so programmable
laboratory information system you need
to put money into starting that up so
where it might not be a percentage an
actual life on direct costs to the test
its overhead I mean to get these things
started to buy the sequencers to buy the
software to staff that train them should
be included in the cost of those testing
the accountants can kind of amateur eyes
that when it comes to the actual direct
costs on the test actually it's fairly
small just because the storages are
pretty cheap and they're getting cheaper
the calculation the compute is getting
cheaper and so when you look at the cost
as the direct cost of tests I would say
you know it's probably ten percent or
less when you do this it at a scale
there are no more questions I would like
to once again thank every black for his
presentation do you have any final
comments yeah I would like to thank
everybody for attending those who will
be watching online later and again I
want to make a plug for Maya prevent
document Solomon who are we talking
about a half hour he definitely will
have a lot to say about the clinical
application as well as the science
behind a lot of the data that I talked
about today so I want to thank everybody
for attending today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
May eleventh 2017 you will receive an
email from lab roots alerting you and
this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your columns who madness
today's of math see you next time
goodbye